in this village in the West African
country of Togo most people eat what
they grow wild animals are sparse on
this mountainous plateau so even little
animals are big-game antelope may not be
appetizing to many people but it's mild
compared to the delicacy silver noose is
preparing to hunt rats for me the meat
of the rat is more delicious than the
meat of the chicken wrap is such a
popular dish in West Africa it's sold in
city markets but in the little village
of Quetta Maine the only way to get this
delicacy is to catch it yourself and
these men are willing to do whatever it
takes in the forests of Togo rats keep
to themselves the best place to look for
them isn't easy to find miles into the
jungle the hunter cieth an abandoned
termite Tower
that's overgrown with brush but the hole
looks very fresh they decide on a plan
to lay siege to the rats strong I'm
plugging the exits of the rat so that he
can't escape once we do that then we can
start digging it's a lot of effort for
the rodent most of us wouldn't want to
meet let alone eat but Silva news and
his friends are getting closer but here
is the bed of the rat here is the fruit
he is eaten today
now we have found the door and we are
sure that he is inside more than an hour
goes by before Silva news can hear the
rat stirring they found their dinner
it's not only a rat it's a giant African
pouch draft which can weigh more than 6
pounds to some it's a test with the
silver news and his friends
it's a delectable morsel taboo or not
the hunters can already taste their
feast
if a tradition holds that those who hunt
get first claim to their quarry a
fortunate custom when pickings are small
the cooks treat this furry rodent like
tenderloin the rat will be cooked with
ground peppers ginger spices and
tomatoes now the meal is complete they
savor every last morsel except the
intestines even the bones inside the rat
bones or vitamins that keep their joints
and bones healthy but eating rat is
about more than nutrition for Silva News
and his friends it's also about
community the hunting and cooking are
done together which makes eating the rat
together more of a pleasure